thank you
[Music]
action Kiara all right you guys know who
Edward Norton's is yeah Norton he's a
famous actor yep he was in that movie
The Glass Onion that everyone was
talking about was he in there he's in a
Morgan history why yes who's in that one
Edward Fight Club he played yes Fight
Club oh the best Hulk movie he played
the Incredible he was a pretty good Hulk
I kind of I thought he was I thought The
Italian Job
remember when he was that guy in the
score
yes oh my God yes he was so good in that
with Robert De Niro yeah he was like
Gilbert grapeing all over the [__]
place it's a good movie he's like
dropping his keys and every scene it's a
good movie it was it was pretty good it
was a great movie yeah
um so did you guys know that well first
of all who do you think is the most
famous Indian no cheating I'm not
looking at Indian most famous Native
American I'm sorry oh NATO oh the
freaking last the Mohicans guy yeah
Sacagawea
the guy who played Saget in Street
Fighter the movie oh yeah dude the Thai
guy who's the second most famous Native
American
like the guy that cries a tear during
the don't literally that's true okay
who's the third most famous Pocahontas
yes so Edward Norton is related to
Pocahontas
wait that means it had to be through
non-consensual I don't know dude his
publicist is working hard this month
does that mean does that mean he gets uh
Pocahontas Casino royalties that's what
we're looking into that right now he's
trying to shake down a couple places
Morongo he's going after Morongo right
now yeah I like that there's a
Pocahontas Casino in your world for sure
what if they had plans to do all this
Pocahontas stuff at Disney and now they
have to call it Edward Norton the ride
the daughter of a 17th century Native
American Chief is his 12th
great-grandmother wow
this a revelation came about on
Tuesday's episode of Finding Your Roots
so his public has got him on that it's a
PBS genealogical history show they are
killing it
um and apparently I need this public so
Didi is this a sponsorship from
ancestry.com and he went on that website
and then he put a spit in a DNA and they
just said where it came from I know but
I just wanted to
ancestry.com hey remember we're friends
we're friends for friends we're friends
we're friends we're alive we're friends
we're pretending to be friends we've
only tried it for years come on come on
play it up
okay right good memories yeah we had a
good time yeah okay
um no so this is a PBS genealogical
history show and there was a family
rumor apparently about this oh that's
right kind of like the Senator Elizabeth
Warren except that it's true and not
completely oh God I got it wasn't
Elizabeth Warren isn't native related to
Sacagawea or anything yeah oh no she's
related to Rachel dolezal so
um that's really good so there is a
there is a uh the family rumor confirms
the family connection to Pocahontas who
supposedly saved Captain John Smith from
execution after welcoming English
settlers to the United States in the
17th century and there is a direct paper
trail connection to uh Pocahontas she
told this person told Edward Norton and
I like Pocahontas that was a dope ass
movie that [__] was banging around it
was a sick movie what about the willow
the whispering Willow The Colors Of The
Wind good one too that sure was banging
around be a man great song not that
movie but a performance
defeat the Huns really good really good
really really good
last one in Pocahontas hey but that's
that means he's kind of related to John
Smith so he has to be yeah so you think
you think he's the most like famous
white man of all time John Smith John
Smith I think he's the most common name
he's the most common name in like an
example driver's license you don't think
John Smith gets enough shine bro yeah
how come he's related to Pocahontas but
not John Smith no he's with John Smith
because John Smith the the PBS
documentary says that John Smith was
beating up significant
yeah there was like 25 minutes dedicated
to do that or was it another guy that
Pocahontas got with that he's related to
well no so Pocahontas died three years
after marrying this cat named Ralph into
Jamestown Virginia what happened to John
Smith I think yeah they fizzled out that
was romanticized via Disney it was
actually a lot darker of a story they
didn't have babies I think John Smith
just kind of hit it and quit it is what
they're saying in the documentary
that was Jamie women because back in
those days you had to be married yeah
um CNN according to CNN historian host
Henry Louise Gates Jr said that John
Smith had a piece and pieced out
oh he deleted that song from the movies
whoa dude but he didn't quit it song the
super misogynistic song that Chris was
doing area codes in that original score
toxic male songs it was peace or peace
oh [__] hey so Johnson Smith was kind of
a piece of [__] then no a piece no [__]
you know they use a piece of [__] I
think most historical figures if you dig
enough you'll find the shitty well dude
Disney I feel like I I was lied to
because I thought he was such a good guy
from a movie I just don't want to say
that John Smith is a piece of [__]
because I don't want to get canceled oh
yeah this is probably his great great
grandfather too you're related to Edward
Norton's racist
uh are you related to Edward Norton
probably who knows so there was a thing
with Edward Norton too where like I
think a whole week before this came out
they were saying that he um was like he
felt bad because he's I think like great
great grandfather something was a slave
owner or something like that
whoa yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah so he was
like explaining how he felt like really
guilty about it and like but you can't
control your past yeah what are you
gonna do dude he wasn't even alive it's
like 17 times removed that's why as long
as you don't own any slaves that's why
when I'm there Edward Norton when I'm
thinking the Publishers is working
really hard I'm like was this done in
contrast to try to counteract yeah
because if he's gonna get royalties from
Pocahontas Casino he's gonna get some
backlash for a backlash shouldn't have
said that why
for his great because we're talking
about the slaves
it's very visual you're too good at
punts that's the problem sometimes no
not good enough I would say Bart um
we're friends on the show yeah we're
friends we're friends we're live right
now how many uh Asians have Genghis Khan
genetics and do you feel bad about that
I don't feel bad at all I was hoping I
was hoping
rapist say that on 23 minutes like yo
Genghis Khan is like this is Daddy yeah
I was hoping I honestly I knew that
wasn't gonna be a thing but in my
fantasy of doing 23 to me I wanted to be
like yeah you're a little bit Mongolian
did it say it yeah no it doesn't it
doesn't mine said one percent really oh
no no Mongolian
you [__] [__]
you guys did
guys on goals out dude some of y'all
were mating nah yeah some of y'all
it's gonna sound like a bit it's not a
bit I found it during Christmas vacation
that my family's related to some kind of
German royalty or some [__] oh all right
now you're braggling
I thought you were a [__] leprecha
I thought you were leprechaun green I
thought you were green like I'm Irish I
thought it was a hell of a lot of German
stuff you're more well you're more
German I am Irish too but like yeah
German it could have been like Greenberg
or something and they shortened because
people have been you know what you know
what I gotta call you out because
because uh oh no you're gonna call me
because because I'm I uh as a as a
person that's with someone who's a
native white she uh she told me you know
Steve Green it's an Irish name but I
don't think he's that Irish and I'm like
why he looks more central European and
northern European and I'm like what's
that like like Norwegian or something
and I'm like really being exposed all my
life I thought it was Stephen green she
really subscribes to this show my fraud
is being reviewed
I uh I don't know I just am such a dummy
that I thought green is like Irish my
selling your creamy [__] pills
you thought you were Irish I got that
text too hey that's great can we talk
about that real quick I thought you were
Irish
if anyone's put on it's Hannah so I will
see it to her yeah she is a [__] pure
redhead yeah yeah she's like she's
original just like I'm just from
Escondido yeah exactly yeah yeah I don't
know what you guys are talking about
Germany same thing he probably knows her
whites really well she knows her wife so
good she's like she's like she's like so
original with Escondido she's like so
original white that they were uh
colonized by Roman whites whoa because
Hannah talking about Steve is like a
Vietnamese fob going like hey Ryan
hasagawa you're not I don't think you're
what you think you are
right it's like I'm from Monterey Park
bro
it's like imagine you got to go running
into that situation I'm just trying to
just like him uh I'm from Monterey Park
bro I'm just trying to do my job by the
way as an Asian from Asia you don't know
[__]
because she's from there yeah I don't
[__] know anything about it yeah I
know more about what an Arizona looks
like your royalty yeah [__] yeah yeah
man but I don't like Royals would you
want to be a farmer what is that no like
a farmer family I don't like the caste
system all the time the Royals are more
related to each other than the commoners
are to the country so it's running from
your Birthright so like you know
European royalty you know how they all
like marry each other right they're all
kind of cousins they're more related
than the countries that they rule oh
again because like you go to Austria
marry that guy or whatever and they're
sending each other like capping the
great is like not even Russian she's
like something else and then she became
you know a queen of Russia or whatever
you call it yeah now I know how Shang
Chi felt yes time for me to face my past
that's right
[Music]
foreign